is the iPhone 14 pro really that much
better than the 13 Pro well in this
video I'm going to skip the specs and
talk about my real world experience
using this new phone every single
difference that I noticed day to day and
I'm going to talk about a couple major
downsides that Apple has to fix as well
as some kind of annoyances and a lot of
improvements that matter now the first
thing I want to talk about is reception
and cellular speeds because that can
make or break if you can actually use
your device now when we first got our
hands on the new phones I tested outside
my office with 5G and it went from 125
with a 13 Pro up to 245 so that is
almost twice the speed and upload from
30 to 46. now I know that some people
say they have faster speeds than that
but keep in mind this is using the same
network at the same place the only
difference is the phone so that's the
kind of upgrade you see but it gets
better I tested at my church where we
only have LTE and I went from 9mp per
second up to 75 and from one upload to
2.45 that is a massive difference with
the only change being the actual phone
and that is because it actually showed
me three bars of reception instead of
one that is crazy now in my basement I
also only have LTE and it is slow but
thankfully it went from 15 megabit per
second up to 65 and from 4 up to 25 that
is so nice to have now I also tested
downtown where we have mid band and it
went up to 555 instead of 350 and 67
upload instead of 60. so if you're
somebody that is struggling with
reception or speeds just upgrade to the
new phone will give you much better
reception and speeds now on the downside
I am struggling with the e-sim now
switching it over wasn't too hard but I
could occasionally get some pop-up
saying my phone number doesn't work
switch to the other one where I only
have one and that is annoying but on the
positive side I also noticed that
Bluetooth is working much better my
range is better the connection goes
faster in particular with my earpods
where sometimes if it doesn't auto
switch to my phone I have to tap on it
it transfers over much quicker than
before now one thing that really popped
out to me was the new display brightness
being able to hit that 2000 nits and
that is so nice if you're outside in the
sun and especially if you do things like
flying a drone now before I remind you
guys of my Horror Story I have to say
that the 13 Pro can hit 1200 nit so it's
not bad but a lot of times it would dim
to 800 if you're using your phone in the
Sun or as low as 300 if you're using
cellular with GPS and it is charging
which also slows down that charging and
it hurts your battery longevity this
video sponsor ESR fixes that with their
just launched fastest massive charger
for iPhones in use level up your Mac
safe with their Halo Lock 3 1 wireless
charger with cryoboost so your wireless
charging won't slow down due to heat and
it increases battery longevity now I was
honestly shocked by how nice this thing
is with its real aluminum parts the
adjustable angles its magnetic alignment
for air pods and that includes a power
adapter and also the spacing is perfect
for the new large camera bumps and the
cooling fan is actually surprisingly
quiet but could also be shut off along
with the lights so I think that this is
the best three-in-one charger for the
price they also have their halalak mini
wireless power banks with an adjustable
kickstand as well as the wire charging
output and a strong magnet that you can
pair with esr's cases that have stronger
magnetic holding Force than Apples like
their Halo lock kickstand case that
gives you added protection and a clever
kickstand or their Chris deck clear case
with very good anti-yellow Wing get 20
off the products by using the links
below with this code or search for ESR
Halo lock on Amazon back to my drone I
crashed and broke it because my phone
owned him so much in the Sun that I
couldn't see anything so that 2000 knit
is so helpful with drones and even for
everyday use out in the sun now yes it
can dim if it gets too hot so it won't
say at 2000 forever but it's still
better than V4 and as for overheating
and dimming when gaming he is dissipated
much better now that apple is focusing
on thermals and it shows and while the
phone does still dim if you start a Max
brightness so far when I've gamed it is
way better than before now as for the
always-on display I'm so happy they
finally added it and it is way better
than Samsung's implementation and one
thing that a lot of people don't know is
that if you have an Apple Watch and you
walk away from your phone that display
will shut off to save battery more on
that in just a bit now I do have one
complaint about it I think in many cases
it is too bright a couple times I
thought it was turned on for example at
church I had my phone next to me and it
looked like it was on I think there has
to be an adjustment for the always on
display brightness in the settings
instead of just that one switch to turn
it off the next thing I want to talk
about is the battery life now that I
have a good amount of use with it and
unfortunately it is worse than expected
now some tests online show that the 14
Pros have better battery life but keep
in mind those tests don't test out the
always-on display with standby or the
peak brightness it's usually capped at
the same with all phones earlier this
week I had 18 left at only 4 30 PM that
is a lot worse than my 13 Pro which is a
year old and only has 91 battery
capacity left now some people have said
that this is because of iOS 16 and I
really hope so because if the battery
life is this bad due to the always-on
display and brightness I will be forced
to use the pro Max this year to get some
decent battery life now one thing that
shocked me were the speakers they are a
huge Improvement in every single way if
you guys want to hear it compared to 13
Pro Max go ahead and take a listen
I know that is probably tough to believe
but Apple's made some huge improvements
not only for music and videos just when
making calls the clarity and the
loudness that you can get is so much
better and that is awesome for
environments that are really loud and
now we have to talk about the dynamic
Island it is cool but I almost want to
call it a gimmick I know some of you
guys might get upset and that's okay I
just want to say that is not a necessity
even though we're so tired of that Notch
I feel like sometimes some things are
slower like face ID popping up for app
downloads and payments just because it
wants to do that cool animation when
watching videos I feel like it is more
distracting If You full screen it
because you see the video moving between
the island and the bezel where's the
Notch was just part of that bezel with
Samsung phones you don't really notice
it because the hole punch is so small
where here the pill is very big and big
because Apple decided to turn off a
bunch of pixels around it to make it
easier for manufacturing which you can
see in Bright Lights it just makes it
look even bigger now as for the cameras
there is a lot to say some really good
and some not so good and annoying but I
want to let you guys know that I'm
making an insanely detailed comparison
like I did last year but with a 14 pro
the 13 Pro and the 12 Pro Max so if you
guys want to see the most concise
comparison of every photo and video mode
make sure you guys click the Subscribe
button down below starting with video
The Cinematic mode is actually usable
now even for YouTube videos way more
accurate it has 4K HDR now and it looks
way better than Samsung flagships even
though they had a two-year Head Start as
far as the action mode it works amazing
not as crazy as it showed off on stage
since they showed off no stabilization
versus the action mode but it is still
very good and once again better than
Samsung's where they also had such a big
head start as for photos my biggest
complaint with the 13 Pro was the poor
HDR for selfie shots compared to Android
as well as poor HDR for the ultra wide
shots and the detail and zoom shots with
that 3x lens now I was really bummed
that Apple did not upgrade the 3x lens
it's the only one that's the same from
the iPhone 13 Pro but thankfully the
shots look a lot better because of the
new processing now not as good as
Samsung's with that 10x camera but it is
still much improved and looks almost
like they put in a new sensor and lens
unfortunately selfie HDR is still
underwhelming and the same thing goes
for Ultra wide shots it has barely
gotten any better and I know that the
cameras are more than capable but Apple
just does not want to pull back the
highlights one thing that has really
surprised me and come in handy is that
2x lens that is fake and now I'm all
against digital crop but in this case it
looks dang good now part of it is
because the uncropped 1X lens doesn't
look that much more detailed than the 12
megapixel photos from the 13 Pro and
that's because Apple doesn't save of it
in 48 megapixels to get the full detail
you have to shoot in Pro raw and then it
looks amazing but the size goes from
about 2 megabytes up to about 75 that is
30 times the file size now Samsung's 50
megapixel photos from the z-fold 4 only
use 12 megabytes compared to their
regular jpegs which use around three so
that is four times larger which makes
sense because you have four times more
pixels so Apple really needs to allow us
to record all the resolution without
having Pro raw now what is even worse is
how apple is handling these if you want
to shoot 40 megapixels because it looks
really good but at the same time you
don't want to keep those massive files
forever there is no easy way to convert
to a small file and delete the raw I had
to do a lot of digging to figure out how
it would be possible and there's a few
ways where you can connect it to your
computer with a cable and use the photos
app but the simplest one I found is to
export your image to the files app let
it upload if it's your iCloud drive and
then select the image and then share it
and move it back to your photo roll and
then go back to photos find the raw and
then delete it and even then that only
works if you edited the image if you
didn't then it will transfer the
original huge file and if you did edit
the image but then you want to transfer
the full resolution to edit well you
can't do that you have to undo all the
edits first and then you can transfer it
this is crazy there should be a pop-up
that asks you which version you want to
export and also an option to convert to
JPEG and automatically delete the raw as
of now apple is just telling people that
the pro raw files take up a lot of space
and you will run out of room and you
should upgrade your storage if you have
iCloud go get the new plan and there's
even a link there to help you to spend
more money alright I gotta calm down a
little bit and just say that after all
this real world use and testing overall
I am very happy mainly due to the
reception and the speed improvements as
well as the convenience of the always-on
display that I wanted for a long time
and the huge speaker boost for me this
is a good upgrade from the 13 Pro and I
would not regret it even if I did not
have this channel so if you guys are
ready for an upgrade you're looking at
the 14 pro I think you'll be very happy
so there you guys go go ahead and click
that subscribe button above if you guys
want to see my super detailed ultimate
camera comparison check out one of those
videos right there this Max and I'll see
you in the next video
[Music]